PROJECT FOR AWESOME!
PROJECT FOR AWESOME! Wooooooooooo
Wooooooooooo Aaaaaaaaahhhhh
Boo boo boo boo
You're gonna see a lot of party poppers in the coming 48 hours
That's good. That's very good
Then but don't forget your eyes
I feel like you guys haven't been donating because you've been watching my face.
Now instead of just controlling the front page, we're actually just doing good things.
Oh my god!
Yaaaaay! (We did it)
Man down!
We can hardly stand the (to) wait. Please Christmas don't be late.
The problem that we're facing right now is truly unprecendented.
We're reaching the highest levels of displacement since World War II.
Don we now our gay apparel.
The Geena Davis Institute
Liberty in North Korea
The Conscious Period
Recycle takes unwanted bikes from the UK and transports them to where they're most needed in Africa. (ayyya)
(What is it?) On this pizza that I'm going to eat at $300,000
Cholula, minced garlic, chocolate chips, ketchup, mustard
(I need a bucket) What is that? (Oh)
Herring is one of my favorite foods too Woofguzbella, but have you ever had a lot of it in a, in a big hurry?
I already love this because it's so much smaller!
Awgh. No. No.
Tyler Oakley's butt has been so many places, including that beanbag!
What are they?
Do you want to do yours? Do you have a happy dance? Show me.
Oh! That's a great happy dance man.
Oh, what are you eating?
Oh, I'm having some herring.
Okay.
Mmmm
Oh no! I hit restart by accident! Oh panic!
*laughing* How do I stop this proce-
Oh. *laughing*
One. Two. Three.
Help me Obi Wan Kenobi. You're my only hope.
It's called the euphoria of non-navigable rivers.
Melanie got a Project for Awesome 2015 mug to keep those toes warm.
We'll lightly patch the butter onto our face. *laughing*
So this is six eggs.
Nope.
*laughter*
*crack* Oh! *laughter*
Back street's back. Alright! What?
Oh Watsky's here. *laughter*
Thank you guys so much! Thank you to everybody who worked so so hard over the last 48 hours. Thanks to everybody in the livestream.
We love you. Happy Project for Awesome!
We will see you - in just 363 short days.
Wooh!
Woo hoo!
I'm so sad it's over.
But it is over. Or is it?
The Indiegogo is still going on so you can go to projectforawesome.com/donate and still get all the great things that are available
The pets of YouTube calendar, the Project for Awesome socks, the commemorative coin, smashed pennies
But, after Midnight Eastern Time tonight, you will never be able to get any of these things ever again
Including all of our very exciting and reasonably priced digital perks
and our most popular perk of the year, the digital perk bundle, which has all of the digital perks alll in one
And finally, maybe most importantly,
Right there, there is a donation card that you can click on and you can donate through that card
and that will still get matched by Google.
They're matching up to $100,000 and they made a deal with the credit card companies
So that every single cent that goes through that button gets passed on to the Foundation to Decrease World Suck.
Thank you so much to everybody who participated this year
Whether you were in the livestream, whether you're volunteering, whether you're donating, whether you're making videos
It really went so well. It was so much fun.
It's a great time and, John, I will see you on Tuesday
and I- and you will see me again on Friday.
It's a double week for me.